within hours of the firing of Tucker
Carlson failed former president Donald
Trump was interviewed on Newsmax this is
an interview as confused as I have ever
seen Donald Trump one of the first
things he was asked about was his
opinion on the firing of Tucker and
what's of course very funny about this
is that we now know Tucker hates Trump
Tucker's text messages revealed in the
discovery process of that Dominion
lawsuit which ultimately led to a nearly
800 million dollar settlement there was
this text message where Tucker said I
hate Trump passionately and I can't wait
until we can stop talking about him so
Trump of course knows that but I think
Trump still realizes that at least in
some sense he may need an ally in Tucker
Carlson for his primary and for his
eventual general election campaign if he
gets there so here is Trump reacting to
the departure AKA firing of Tucker from
Fox so Tucker Carlson was sitting here
two weeks ago interviewing you he's gone
what do you make of that well I'm
shocked I'm surprised he's a very good
person a very good man and very talented
as you know and he had very high ratings
so
we're just learning about it almost as
we speak now a couple people wrote to me
and there's more to this which we'll
look at saying you know David
if you read the expression on Trump's
face this little smirk
Trump is saying one thing but projecting
another one with the smirk and that's
Trump's reaction which is Tucker got
what was coming to him because he said
bad things about me in those text
messages it's an interpretation I don't
know you make of it what you will you
and I just said wow that was something
that's a big one uh I don't know if it
was voluntary or was it was somebody
fired but I think Tucker's been terrific
he's been especially over the last year
or so he's been terrific to me there's a
lot of turmoil over there at Fox I mean
787 they just paid why would they get
rid of a guy who's performing why would
somebody do that to their business
because they're losing money right now
their stock has gone down well I was
surprised that they made a settlement on
that case I thought that was the case
that should easily be won
and they made a settlement look you'll
have to ask them I'm not I'm not
representing them at all by any by any
means but the Tucker uh situation again
you don't know if it's a firing maybe he
left because he wasn't being given his
free reign he wants free reign maybe but
now of course we know that Tucker was
indeed fired and we know that there were
many problems Tucker's coverage
partially responsible for the lawsuit
that led to the settlement Tucker saying
horrible things about Fox Management in
text messages released as part of that
lawsuit Tucker currently sued for having
a discriminatory misogynistic sexist
racist uh uh uh production apparatus and
potentially another lawsuit coming from
rayap so Fox News realized at least to
some degree that Tucker became a problem
for them continuing on this very
confusing Newsmax interview we saw
DeSantis asked by Hannity about Trump
now we see Trump asked by Greg Kelly
about DeSantis and Trump takes a
different approach than DeSantis did
want to get to Nixon in a moment by the
way Rhonda santis do you think he could
be a good president someday in like
eight years 16 years I mean you endorsed
him once he's got some Talent you're
kind of crushing him right now someday
could he be president well I endorsed
him once and he was losing badly and
because of the endorsement he wanted a
landslide the following literally the
following day look right now I'm very
down on him I'm a Believer in loyalty
and I'm a Believer in other things and
he has obviously not run a very good
campaign because he's getting he's
getting crushed Now understand that
there is no campaign yet that's the most
interesting thing about this Trump is
acting as though DeSantis is running a
campaign now you could argue well he
sort of is but he hasn't announced
because he's feeling it out okay it's
not actually a campaign and there's a
question as to if and how the Dynamics
will change I really don't know how
don't know him you know I don't know him
that well I agreed to endorse him he
came over to see me he was one of a
hundred people that fought a little bit
on the impeachment hoax number one
impeachment hoax number two they were
hoaxes they were just hoaxes and based
on that I did it because I didn't know
the people he was running he was running
against a man that was way up in the
polls leading by a massive amount that
election was over when I endorsed him
the election was over in Ron's favor I
mean it was Ron was getting ready to
quit
so I don't know I I'm very disappointed
in him because I'm uh a loyal person
maybe that's really what this is all
about he could have just skipped to that
to a fault I'm a loyal person and
somebody gets you into office and then
you're telling people well I don't know
if I'll run against the president you
know I mean life shouldn't have to work
that way and there it is the anecdote I
regularly refer to which is DeSantis was
asked would you rule out running against
Trump and he didn't rule it out Trump
remembers
Trump bringing up that anecdote he has
not forgotten about that the topic of
the January 6 riots came up as it often
does and uh listen to what Trump had to
say this this is really wild stuff the
weaponizing law enforcement at a level
that nobody's ever seen before and it's
very dangerous to the country and our
country is not going to stand for it you
know we have very strong people in this
country and they've been sitting back
and watching they've been watching
they've watched that whole situation at
the Capitol they didn't walk in with
guns they shot Ashley Babbitt that
officer bad things should happen to him
he shot her
and she was totally defenseless she was
like an American Patriot you look at her
she was a patriot listen
that's been investigated and it's
interesting to continue to hear the
people who say we support the police we
defend the police
etc etc all of a sudden say hey even
though there was an extensive
investigation into the death of Ashley
Babbitt and the officer was found not at
fault
they insist that the officer did
something wrong why is that it's because
that principle of we support the police
only when it's convenient online the
flag and the whole thing
she was an American Patriot they shot
her and nothing happened to him if that
were the other way around it would have
been hell to pay but the people of this
country just aren't going to take it
anymore well I don't know exactly what
Trump means by that is he alluding to
violence is he alluding to how people
will vote we never know last clip Donald
Trump asked about his former Attorney
General William Barr
gets a little dicey and most of my
people were smart and tough I had some
bad ones I mean I wish I had a better
attorney general somebody that was
tougher that wasn't afraid to fight you
should have been fighting instead of
being afraid to be impeached he was
petrified of being impeached just
petrified it made him uh there's a
couple of words I could use I would
never use the word impotent of course
but
it made him
absolutely useless when it came to
election fraud and so many other things
and now he sits back and he pontificates
with you know some some of these uh
various shows that are on uh I wish I
had a better attorney general well
remember Trump ran on I will hire the
absolute best people and so by his own
standards if there is anybody to blame
for William Barr it is Trump himself so
this is what I expect to continue in
terms of DeSantis versus Trump whether
or not listen even if DeSantis doesn't
announce until the point at which
DeSantis says I'm not running if that is
what is coming this is what we're going
to see we are going to see Trump
continuing to attack the Santos for
disloyalty and DeSantis playing the I'm
too good for this I'm too classy for
this I'm above it thing which only makes
him look weak to the average Republican
voter we will have more we're going to
take a quick break Lindsey Graham had
his bubble popped on CNN yesterday and
many other things to discuss with you if
you're looking for the perfect Mother's
Day gift our sponsor Aura frames creates
incredible Ultra quality digital frames
we're displaying pictures and videos you
can pre-load the frame with your
favorite memories pictures videos for
Mom to see when she opens it up you can
update it with unlimited photos and
videos from anywhere using the aura
frames app no fees ever no limits on
storage Aura frames was voted the number
one digital picture frame by wire cutter
the strategist and Wired Magazine my mom
loves the frame I gave her I also have
an aura frame in my house when we were
just traveling I was able to immediately
add pictures which pop up on my mom's
frame and I've noticed the photos look
like real prints such high resolution
and the display is calibrated so that
you can not even tell it's a screen Aura
frames has an awesome Mother's Day deal
for my audience you'll get up to thirty
dollars off their best-selling Carver
map frame and free shipping go to
auraframes.com Pacman use the code
Pacman the link is in the description